[Musik]
jetzt wirds aber interessant weil die
leute ja keine
[Musik]
lisa marie agnes strack zimmermann von
der fdp ja escape to one night in
hongkong er aber es keine schweinerei
auch in dir one hyde alles gut ja sogar
höchst schweinerei wirklich in steyr ein
bisschen ist dabei der damen und herren
wir schalten jetzt um dieses programm
ist ab 18
bis zur mitte der 90er jahre gab es in
hongkong die so genannte world city
haben sie vielleicht schon gehört ein
praktisch rechtsfreier raum in dem man
ohne staatliche einmischung aller leiten
geschäfte machen kommt ja aber es ist
doch wie im bundestag der aber klingt
auch wie wie der feuchte traum der fdp
oder feucht
wir reisen jetzt nach hongkong ohne
flugzeug sie müssen nur hier rein gehen
sie vor
haben sie sich schon mal was kriminelles
gemacht außer der fdp mit vier ja ich
habe mit acht jahren ein tütchen tritt
geklaut wirklich und bin vor der tür
gestanden und habe meinen freunden
gesagt ich hab's das war doof oder nicht
vertretbar wäre ja das war der anfang
einer kriminellen karriere die just
wieder beendet war
ich rannte dann losgerannt hinterher
erreichte mich im schulhof und fragte
mich ob sie die eltern oder die lehrer
informieren sollte ich hab gesagt direkt
zu den eltern so war nicht lustig aber
trete er sich immer noch gern sie
schauen sich hier um jaich findet man
auch was hier was man gebrauchen kann
durch hier ist ein eimer sie müssten
sich anpassen wir können ein
leiharbeiter besorgen und chinesischen
wenn sie das wünschen ist ja damit
stäbchen oder so sehen so die stäbchen
ich nehme an ich brauche das mit 1
ich würde also es steht ja hier nicht
umsonst sehr klar ich würde mal mit
leben ok also hier geht es weiter dann
würde ich sagen wir gehen weil hier
durch
ich will sie nicht unnötig unter druck
setzen aber ich bin sowas von unter
druck luise amtsberg können sie von den
grünen jetzt ich kenn ihn nicht ich will
dich kenn ja wieso ich wünsche dass
seine kollegin ja gut kenne ich ja ok ja
didier hat diesen raum auch schon ihr
habt ja und die hat unfassbar gut
gemacht die grünen haben ja auch gerade
im lauf der havag der von der perforce
echtes ist super sie müssen wir die
regeln und aufschreiben analysieren ja
ich muss immer im deutschunterricht
bringen und dann analysieren wie er
bleibt nicht viel übrig aber sound ist
gut weswegen sie ist jetzt auch er ist
genau der weg ja aber haben wir kennen
sie wirklich nicht nur diese angst mit
die müssen sie auch schon mal gesehen
habe das sind doch nur noch grüne im
bundesrat stimmt zumindest so die sehen
alle so aus sie es haben alle wege sind
schon traurig ist dass mit ihm und
begann ersten sie vegan
nein weil ich weiß gar nicht was das ist
das alles ohne augen nicht ich esse
alles in butter ich es ja ich esse nicht
wie gern schmeckt auch trocken und dröge
[Musik]
oh ja jetzt er sieht aus wie ein bordell
ich war noch nie ein aber es sieht ein
bisschen aus so muss es aussehen also
die frau amtsberg ja gern aber die hat
limburger durch getan
[Applaus]
pascal ist wieder da aber das kommt
ihnen vielleicht auch ein bisschen
bekannt es kommt mir bekannt vor das ist
wie so eine disco in den 70er jahren der
stange sie gehen direkt und zielstrebig
kennen sie die aus dem büro von rainer
brüderle
er hatte keine stange das sollten wir
jetzt nicht aber ich bin es interessant
wie zielstrebig ja daher weil da müssen
wir noch gar nicht hin so gut so und
jetzt ja das frage ich sie wir müssen
weiter wir müssen weiter sie können sich
immer so ein bisschen umschauen was sie
hier so sehr ist die stange da habe ich
nicht dran tanzen ich meine das wäre
meine neue freundin ja vielleicht später
sagen
so sieht ein bisschen aus dem
beichtstuhl aber ich glaube es ist eher
nicht moment ähnliches man fühlt sich
nah bei gott sagen was ja irgendwie
irgendwie ja ja was ist denn das hier
eine wahlkabine
es fängt auch mit den wahlkabinen
kleiner buddha figuren sind sehr gut das
habe ich sammle die hostie chance als
fdp mitglied in den himmel zu kommen hat
das weiß ich jetzt nicht ob das so
erstrebenswert ist das ist ja bekannt
dass in der hölle mehr partie ist also
doch die wälder ich glaube die lustigen
leute sind kunden und die anderen sind
oben
aber ich höre ich bin fdp ich würde mir
das gerne flexibel hat
so also das mache ich jetzt mit denen
also ich würde sagen ich habe ihn ja
schon mal den hinweise gebe ich
wiederhole es eigentlich noch mal mit
der stange nichts mit der stange
ich hab ihm gesagt die stadt ganz gut
der eine stand auch schon mal ganz gut
da hinten was verrückten sie das denn
also der franz berg ist das nicht
passiert also die finanzmärkte hat die
direkt richtig hingestellt revidierte
hingestellt als die muss man hier dieses
jahr also die bkw herein die fragen zu
werken also meiner lebens stellt die
frauen zwar schon längst durch ich so
was hat sie weiterleben
ungelöst sehr unterschiede was für eine
langweile rinn und so war es jetzt so
hinstellen ja also das sind jetzt zwei
wir ja aber was sehen sie was sehe ich
was euch sehen wir essen.de könnte es
vielleicht sein dass wir noch zwei
weitere sich aber jetzt wirklich drin
wir noch mehr
das hat sie ein bisschen übertrieben
[Musik]
und sowas ja wie topfschlagen kann mir
einer helfen
[Musik]
die vorarlberg hat sogar ein fünfter
geschnitzt in der zeit und jetzt was
passiert ist
sie müssen jetzt da unten die farben
nennen und ich werde sie drittens
berühren sagt das kloster ist guckt
genau hin
ich glaube sie haben die tankstelle
gemacht dann wäre das jetzt ihr hören
[Musik]
so steht jetzt auf zwei feldern ja
typisch erste fehler immer mehr mehr
mehr so jetzt nochmal jetzt noch mal
lila jetzt mit einem nur mit einem jetzt
hat weiß gelingen himmels willen eine
tür geht auf eine tür geht er auf eine
tür eine tür und wer geht rein
ja sie die ich soll da reingehen aber
wir sind jetzt hier tatsächlich einer
opiumhöhlen wenn die grünen alle skipper
sind und die csu leute alles alkoholika
was ist die droge der fdp
brooks speed oder gekochter sind wir
flexibel erhoffen seien immer offen sein
aber wenn das so ne opium zweifelhaft
sei opium wird ja auch gegen depression
tatsächlich verwendet wollen wollen sie
was für christian lindner mit mit geben
falls es neuwahlen gibt
sie meinen einen richtigen zug ja aber
das ist super da wird aus einer 10
direkt und 20 da muss so lange genug
kaufen
irgendwann 200 angekommen das wollen
nämlich aber wir fangen sie jetzt mal an
diese diese die erben satz von von
lindner zum thema freiheit ist future so
sagt das muss man den profis überlassen
es war doch mist oder also das was sind
das für das kam jetzt wollte man uns die
leute auch mal stehen lassen
der hund tut nix ich mein das spiel ist
ja ich glaube dass er selber nicht ganz
glücklich war darüber ja ja
oder ist das durchaus liberale
positionen zu sagen wir lassen dem klima
die freiheit sich so zu erwärmen wie es
will
die das liberale wir lassen ist das
liberal
also ich kenne das klimakterium dem habe
ich die freiheit gelassen und das war
richtig heiß machen fühlt man niemals
aus
fragen sie mal ihre zuschauerinnen ach
das ist ein scheiß thema für die fdp
wird
[Musik]
jetzt wird es aber interessant könnte
man den fall ja ich kann ob die drogen
haben mich nicht so und jetzt passiert
was passiert jetzt hat es geklappt
hier ist etwas passiert an diesem
schrank
man kann eigentlich so wie sind sie
machen das schon sehr gut aber glauben
sie ein mann hätte die lösung schneller
gewusst kubicki zum beispiel ist so ein
typ der die tür eingetreten
ja ja er hält sich nicht große aufgabe
mit schloss der tritt dagegen ja dass
sie müssen da so team rein wie sich die
jamaika-koalition ich ja gebaut wo die
3d grafik so was haben uns so was von
tiefer
so jetzt was spielt man sonst so bei der
fdp monopoly gehe direkt ins gefängnis
oder los das ärgert mich immer sehr wenn
man direkt im knast muss und nicht seine
4000 euro einziehen darf beim ich kaufe
die badstraße niedrigwasser wird hier
auch kernsaniert ja logisch diene teuer
gemacht was der badstraße wird die
straße so die fdp
ja sind wir hier zum spaß nein also
genau ich mir das vorgestellt wie die
fdp
und dann kaufen haben die e werke und
wasserwerken und da wird richtig teuer
sowas passiert was muss passieren dass
sehen sie dann das weiß ich noch nicht
beamte wer sie glück haben fühlen sie
sich wie die grünen dann ist das so so
will ich mich gar nicht vielen reisen
traurig das leben ist so traurig schauen
soll ich das mir aus motorrad und
steuern die am leben und esther niveau
ist ein korridor und fühle mich wohl und
die ist ein echte keine vegane man
richtig bewusst da ist man schon
eingelaufen weg jetzt ist ne wurst hier
dreimal diese erklärt das ist natürlich
was machen wir da jetzt mit das ist die
frage die ich in ställe und wie sie
jetzt alleine herausfinden müssen
3 x 63 x 63 x 6 wo könnte man dreimal 6
jetzt ist wieder die frage der
reihenfolge erst das ist ja immer wobei
natürlich bei drei mal sechs die frage
der reihenfolge nicht so richtig jetzt
ist da sehr gut was erwarten sie dass da
drin sein könnte gift mit gift verklappt
ja ihr habt verklappt irgendwo in der
nordsee oder die geschredderten vögel
wir lesen ja immer wie viele vögel drauf
gehen weil die in die windräder ja ja
die reste müssen ja irgendwie und die
werden dann versenkt und was haben wir
so weiter
wer ist das wohl ehemalige
parteivorsitzende der sozialdemokratie
so gehen die mit ihrem oder der letzte
fdp wähler im osten nein auch sein das
ist frau nahles ich erkenne ich sie
sofort und sie war so gut drauf wie soll
man da jetzt raus holen da nicht
wirklich wissen sie was ich mich frage
was macht eigentlich philipp rösler
meinen sie gehört konstruktion irgendwie
weil sie das ist harris ist er wusste
das war eine frau die da drin sitzt oder
liegt ein schlüssel habe ich immer an
die wäsche gehen sie mal die wäsche so
und wir haben ein schlüssel ja sehr gut
jetzt wird es richtig spannend fußbank
endspurt wofür brauchen wir den
schlüssel
jetzt muss ich druck machen jetzt wird's
spannend jetzt wird es spannend nähe
haben noch 60 sekunden
[Musik]
genauso die freiheit wir haben doch
günstig und 54
nicht erschrecken dass alles gut dadurch
vielleicht doch lieber geld mitnehmen
weiß ja nie was unternehmer päckchen mit
man weiß ja nie wie viel es ist sehr gut
kokett man so kennt man die cdu nicht
hier raus hier das wäre ich nur inne wie
fühlt sich das an einer kleinen
kriminellen vereinigung einkommen zu
sein wechsel wird sie passe ich fühle
mich gut ich habe dem ich hab den die da
standen ihren kohle ist die da geblieben
ich habe opium geraucht und formal ist
wünsche ich alles alles gut
ich wünsche ihnen auch alles gute das
nächste mal sitzen sie da eine tonne
so schnell geht's jetzt habe ich angst
ja an der stelle soll ich jetzt
eigentlich erklären dass hier ein
leichter lassen sollte aber frau strack
zimmermann hat mir gerade erklärt wie
das mit der wirtschaft funktioniert die
kaufe ich mir jetzt einfach aber zur
sicherheit lasst doch mal lag da und
abonniert den kanal ok 500 1000 1500 bis
2000 likes 1500